internet this peu à peu sa toile dans
les écoles françaises
ainsi près de trouville dans le calvados
une école les connecter un village
virtuel
une manière originale d'apprendre
l'histoire une français la preuve
haussier qu'internet peut être utile
mais il n'est pas toujours facile de
convaincre les maires des petites
communes
nicolas le marine et aurélie legrand à
l'école de saint-etienne la tiède
internet c'est un grand bond dans le
passé chaque semaine les cm1-cm2
visitent le site danville accords blinn
un bourg imaginaire où le temps s'est
arrêté en 1866 les enfants dialoguent
avec les habitants du village et il faut
tout expliquer à félicien l'agriculteur
ou henry l'aubergiste
cet ordinateur
akai éprouvions portes de vin trouver
les mots justes formuler des phrases
correctes la correspondance impose un
gros travail d'expression écrite en
classe et aussi une recherche
documentaire
il ya tout le côté aussi recherche qui
font sur internet qu'ils font sur le
site dans vie qui font dans la
bibliothèque dans les dictionnaires et
qui leur permet aussi de
d'apprendre plein de choses et l'autre
côté de l'écran des animateurs bénévoles
jouent le rôle des habitants du village
leur tâche apporter une information
historique aux élèves convaincre les
petites communes d'adopter internet
n'est pas une chose face thierry
lâcherait supervise le programme en vie
c'est un pilier de l'informatique à
l'école dans le calvados village après
village on lui pose les mêmes questions
à quoi ça va servir
est-ce bien rentable d'investir une
partie non négligeable 10 ans du budget
communal dans l'achat d'un ordinateur
pour ce qui est du coup le conseil
général du calvados payent la moitié du
matériel tir il assurait lui répond aux
inquiétudes des mères informatique c'est
quoi après pour les impôts les enfants
pour des gamins un ordinateur fait quoi
à saint-etienne l'informatisation a
coûté quinze mille francs seulement
90% des écoles de la circonscription de
trouville sont reliés au net en france
fin 2001 tiers seulement accéder au web